I've seen stories with you and Tupac and
I've seen you talk about Tupac a lot and
it's emotional stories did you ever have
any interaction with Biggie or I mean
listen I first met biggie when I came
back and I fought um
either with Peter McNeely uh
Peter McNally are either Frank Bruno and
um I had a party at my house and he came
biggie yeah and at the time I was really
religious and I was a prick and Hey
listen he kept can't drink so he shot
the drink down came in the house and he
was very impressed he asked how much the
house close and at the time it was six
million and that was cool to him back
then but he would to continue to live it
would have been like buying a candy bar
for him but listen to him and he was
just a cool guy then I met him again at
Nell's it was just a really nice cool
guy how different were were he and Tupac
personality-wise
Biggie's smooth laid-back guy
pocket the real energetic power feed the
personality boom explosive
but they both Geminis too
you know who else is a Gemini oh Trump
shoot Elvis uh Marilyn Monroe Brad Pitt
Angelina Jolie Johnny Kennedy they're
crazy crazy you're crazy my wife my
wife's a Gemini
we got time in common cause I'm a Gemini
yeah
listen listen don't have they they don't
let grudges go Gemini's no they need to
chill out on grudges we got to go
through a list of Geminis you've crossed
and say you know what I got to call
these seven guys if they get mad at you
oh God they want to kill you so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign